your name is the latest anime film out
of Japan for Makoto Shinkai the guy who
brought us the garden of words children
who chase lost voices voices of a
distant star all types of great anime
films he likes to tell stories about
people who are sort of like star-crossed
lovers that have something that's
keeping them apart he's good at it but
it's definitely his wheelhouse and your
name fits right in with that except
there's something incredibly unique
about this film that I've honestly never
seen in live-action or anime and that is
that this is a body swapping film this
movie opens with a young girl named
mitsuo who wakes up and begins to touch
herself and realizes that oh my god I
have girl parts now that's normal for a
girl her age except for the fact that
taki a boy who also lives in Japan is
currently inhabiting her body so that's
weird and that same boy taki wakes up in
Japan begins to touch himself and
realizes oh my god I have man parts down
there
that's because Mitsu ha and taki have
switched bodies and the story of this
film is these two characters who
randomly wake up as each other swapping
bodies without any warning and they have
to figure out how to spend a day in the
other person's body they have to figure
out why this is even happening and
eventually they kind of grow to
appreciate one another as they learn
about each other's lives in an extremely
unconventional way and in an anime film
that I loved watching I got to see this
film at the Laemmle Music Center in LA
it's currently the only place in the
United States showing it because it's a
limited Oscar qualifying run I was
really lucky to be in LA when this film
opened I drove like an hour in an uber
to get to this theater and it was like
the only showing that wasn't completely
sold out I was in a theater filled with
Japanese people I must have been like
the only white dude there it was really
cool actually because I saw it with a
crowd that understood it this is a film
that you will appreciate more if you
have a varied background in watching a
lot of anime or if you have a knowledge
of Japanese culture because there's a
lot of humor here that you will never
see in an American film and it's so
refreshing it's also a very different
story I've never
Cina romance told through body-swapping
which is a very very unique way of doing
it and the unique Japanese humor that's
in this film combined with breathtaking
hand-drawn traditional cel animation
make your name one of my favorite movies
I've seen in 2016 this is an emotionally
powerful film that isn't just very funny
but has a great way of really tugging at
your heart strings without feeling too
much like a soap opera I know a lot of
people are probably going to see this
film and especially if you don't have a
background in watching a lot of anime or
if you don't know much about Japanese
culture a lot of people are going to say
this is a super melodramatic soap opera
movie that just is for teenagers or
whatever but it's not it's a lot more
than that this film has a beautiful way
of examining youth culture in Japan and
what can make two people fall in love
even if they've never actually met
because they're learning about each
other's lives by actually being that
person for a day and so you you know
more about the other person than you
ever possibly could which is such a cool
way to tell a romance in a film and I
know I already mentioned this but I must
reiterate the animation in this movie is
beautiful it's so gorgeous I love
traditional hand-drawn cel animation I'm
so sad that America has almost
completely abandoned it in favor of CG
animation which is fun and enjoyable and
I don't have a problem with that it's
just I love hand-drawn animation and I'm
so happy that Japan is sticking with it
because it is a beautiful thing to see
in this film the characters are so well
realized they're so likable in the film
also has a great way of transitioning
from fun and humorous to serious and
emotionally powerful and somewhat
suspenseful actually a lot of drama D
style films have a hard time doing that
where it starts off and you're like oh
this is all laughs and all of a sudden
like people are dying and it's like oh
this is really serious all of a sudden a
lot of films have a hard time bridging
that gap between those very different
feels this is a beautifully animated
film that serves as a heartfelt reminder
that even though Miyazaki has supposedly
retired we still have great directors
like Mamoru Hosoda
and Makoto Shinkai making great anime
films I'm going to give your name and
a plus I honestly don't have a single
problem with this movie I think that if
you are a big anime fan and if you like
films from this filmmaker in particular
you're going to love this movie some
people who aren't as familiar as I said
with anime or Japanese culture are not
going to love it as much as I did I
would say if you aren't a big anime fan
this will be more like a B+ for you but
if you understand anime and you
understand the humor that comes out of
Japan that's often in these types of
films and you appreciate the
unconventional romance then you're going
to probably enjoy it as much as I did
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I greatly appreciate it and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you